est-ce que tu trouves qu'elle est jolie
oui pour moi
oui c'est la plus jolie femme que tu
connais bien sûr pourquoi bien s parce
que c'est maman unteau bleu clair avec
un col de fourure c'est joli
alors ça va bien comment sa voit douce
et en quoi peut pas être remplacé en
gentillesse et en affection une personne
peut en avoir une affection mais pas la
même fait pas tout ce qu'une mère nous
fait un père ça tricote pas les pil vert
par exemple ça fait pas la
cuisine quelqu fois ça fait pas la
cuisine
elle fait bien la cuisine ta mère très
bien elle te fait des plat que tu aimes
bien ah oui quoi par exemple les UF durs
les durs et les au bacon c'est parce
qu'elle te fait à manger c'est parce que
parce que j'aime trop c'est
tout c'est Simp tu l'aimes
trop